- It's your accent,
it's your this.
It's 'cause your mom told
you weren't good enough.
There's so many things.
What's your alternative?
I just think that
people are scared to
fail in front of other people.
My friends, I'm telling
you something right now,
I'm desperately excited to
fail in front of you.
Because A, I don't really give a
fuck what you think and
B, I'm gonna learn from it and
C, battle scars are attractive.
(hip hop music)
Just gonna grab a coffee.
The calm before the storm.
- [Man] So we've got about--
- [Gary] 130?
- [Man] 130 people.
All in the tech industry,
about three quarters of them are
marketers,
VPs of marketing, CMO's--
- Of like what
kind of companies?
- [Man] Mostly startup to
midsize tech companies.
- [Gary] Okay.
B-to-B or B-to-C?
- B-to-B, 100%.
- I'm so excited to meet you.
- I'm excited too.
- Yes. Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- What do you
want to walk up to?
- Music-wise?
- Yeah.
- Oh, anything.
Maybe some Bone
Thugs And Harmony?
- Not familiar but I'll find it.
- Anything you do is fine.
Biebs is great.
- No, I'm serious.
- Thank you so much.
- Don't forget to read my...
- Oh yeah, I want to read it.
- [Woman] You don't
have to do it right now.
- I want to though.
But maybe you shouldn't
be here while I read it.
- No, probably not.
We'll take it again?
Alright, let's take it again.
- I appreciate you coming.
- Thank you for having me.
- And sharing your knowledge.
- Thank you.
- It's important that our team
learn these kind of skills that
you have out there.
- Yeah, I mean it's funny
I'm passionate about
the B-to-B space.
I think a lot of people think
social media is for the
B-to-C space--
- Right.
- so I'm excited about who's
in the audience tonight.
Should be good.
- Well, nice to meet you.
- Yeah, no worries.
Tonight? You know
what's so funny?
I used to always make fun of
sports announcers who would be
calling a day game and they
would say, "Tonight the Knicks
"play the Bulls," I'm like it's
1:30 in the afternoon and now
it's fricking 9:30 and I'm
like great audience tonight.
It's so weird how
your brain does that.
Sorry.
Baby Arielle and Ari are going
to be great because I really
think Musical.ly it's about
to stick and its landing.
It'd be awesome to look
back at early episodes of like
Twitter stars or Vine stars
or YouTube stars.
- Yeah, before it was.
- I mean I knew Phil DeFranco
when he had four followers on
YouTube. You know?
- That's awesome.
- Even Casey when he was first
on me didn't blow up yet as you
are wear your Beme shirt.
Hey Casey great
news I found a fan.
Look at his Beme
shirt DRock's rocking.
D-Beme.
Okay, we can do
it tomorrow then.
Yeah, we can do it tomorrow.
Okay I got to go I think.
See ya.
- [Woman 2] And I want
you to all please
welcome Gary Vaynerchuk.
(applause)
- [Gary] Thank you.
Thank you.
You found Bone Thugs And
Harmony, I'm impressed.
Facebook running ads against
60-year-olds saying,
"Are your parents in
need of our services?"
Here's one thing that I know
about 60-year-olds on Facebook.
This is how a 22-year-old goes
through their feed on Facebook.
Here's how a 60-year-old
goes through their feed.
That's what I'm interested in.
Attention. Attention.
Imagine walking into your
business right now if it's your
business, I got an idea.
We're going to
become a media company.
We're gonna hire an
editor-in-chief for
150,000 a year.
We're gonna hire some staff
writers, a video person and
we're going to launch a site
called Small Business Daily.
People are going to be like what
the fuck's the matter with you?
In the same way they would have
if you said social media's going
to be a big thing and you
can sell stuff there.
We represent a bunch of
influencers, we do a lot of
stuff with them I have
14-year-old girls on Musical.ly
making $500,000 a year.
Lip-synching. Right?
That's not something businesses
believed 36 months ago.
My whole life, my whole life has
been on anticipating where the
world's going and by the
way back to that gentleman's
question in the back that
started it off with the
Pokémon, 24 months from now
because I can hold up my
business for 24 months
to get there.
Not six years, I'm not
developing VR wine technology
right now 'cause I don't think
it's 24 months but media is now
and definitely 24 months.
It's just not how people think.
I'm empathetic of getting
laughed out of the room.
Guys, I really
appreciate your time.
Thank you.
(applause)
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Thank you, brother.
Springfield.
Oh no kidding?
- Where are you?
- I live in the city now but
I almost opened a store in
Aberdeen which is
very close to you guys.
- Right, right, right.
Thanks a lot.
- [Gary] Thanks, brother.
- [Woman 2] You can meet with
Gary over in the social lounge.
- I'm Tricia Baglio.
- Thank you Trisha, thank you.
I got to hear about
the first 40 minutes--
- Thank you.
I hope you enjoyed it.
- I did.
- Thank you.
- And of course,
they pulled me.
- And they're like, "Let's go."
- I'm like going,
"But I want to hear the rest."
- Thank you.
Thank you.
- Health care
vertical for marketing.
- So, I mean--
- So, who's the target?
- Physicians,
doctors, facilities.
- Hospitals.
- What are you
trying to sell them?
- Well, it's our service.
We do a lot of lot of
management for them--
- Yep.
- but now are also
growing it with IT.
- Okay.
- All the products with
networking in that stuff.
And so--
- Think about it backwards.
Think about
everything in articles.
Why physicians, why hospitals
need to start caring about
privacy and then
write that article.
Why independent physicians
need to understand Snapchat.
And write that article.
I reverse engineer.
Once you start with what you
think they should be thinking
about like whatever IT
you're selling there's a why.
There's a why you think
you they should have it.
- Right, right.
- Don't be the doctor that
loses your patient's data.
- Yeah.
- Article.
Then that article or video
is deployed against
physicians on LinkedIn.
Against physicians on Facebook.
Understand?
- What I am afraid
of with Facebook--
- Go ahead.
- is because the physician--
- Yes.
- is not really into Facebook.
- [Gary] Who says? You?
- I see from my clients--
- Your focus groups of
five or 50 is too small.
- Okay. True.
- You don't think Dr. John
is on fucking Facebook?
- [Man 3] It's true.
- [Woman 3] You'd be surprised
you start talking to people
you'd be surprised
what they are into.
- All my physicians
are on Facebook.
I have three.
They're all there.
I see their fucking pictures.
They're there as
John not as Dr. John.
Doesn't mean John doesn't see
the video and if John sees why
physicians should start worrying
about data John might read that
when he's having his
coffee on Tuesday morning.
- [Woman 4] Mhmmm. Okay.
- [Gary] That's the problem.
People make decisions
on their focus group.
Musical.ly's going to be big.
People send me an email, "Well,
my 14-year-old daughter says
"it's not cool anymore."
Mazel Tov but your 14-year-old
daughter is not every fucking
14-year-old in America.
So the data shows that plenty
of doctors are on Facebook.
Probably most of them.
- [Woman 4] Alright.
Well, thank you.
- You got it.
- [Woman 4] Do you mind if we
take a picture with you, Gary?
- Sure.
- [Woman 5] One, two, three.
- Thanks, Gary.
- Take care, brother.
- [Man 4] You too.
- [Gary] Stay well.
- So starstruck about
asking my question?
- Yes.
- Okay, I'm sorry.
- No worries.
- So I have two.
(hip hop music)
- [DRock] Whatcha doing, Gary?
- Shhh, DRock.
A lot of times one of the things
I've always historically have
done, was really good at in 2011,
'12, '13 when I was a little bit
less busy, harder now but
Ifound a little pocket 'cause a
call just got canceled is engage
with the content produced from
the keynote that I give.
It's a never ending cycle of
engagement, context,
brand building,
relationship building.
And so you give a talk, people
to tweet about it, really at
the height of Twitter when
people were live tweeting it was
incredible, a lot of times when
I was in Europe or far away from
the airport of where where I
gave the talk that whole hour,
two hours I just engage with
everybody that made pro, con,
you know, luckily my speaking
95% positive, 3% indecisive,
2% mad that I cursed.
.01%, .05% people
adamantly disagreeing.
And so you would engage
pro, con, indifferent.
A lot of thanks, a lot of
winkeys, a lot of now with the
way Twitter works just
even giving a heart
makes people that
you know that you saw it,
it's kind of like, it's funny.
I used a reply now the heart's
even quicker, the like,
the heart whatever you want
to call it on Twitter.
I think people
underestimate the wink.
The head nod.
Actually this is very weird,
somebody said,
somebody just tweeted,
I want to do it verbatim.
I want to get it right.
That moment that you walk in
to the room and you and GaryVee
give each other a head nod you
know it's going to be a good day
or something like that.
That's what a heart is.
This guy just
mentioning seriously
genuineness stuff,
boom, a little heart there.
From a guy.
Boom, a little heart there.
Now Tom knows that I saw it,
I appreciate it.
Don't estimate a wink.
Acknowledging another human
being in a positive way
takes all forms.
It can be a four hour dinner
or to be a quick little, I love
looking at people when I walk or
strangers my whole life in the
airport I do it a ton.
I'll just look at
them and be like...
It's powerful.
Driving positivity,
acknowledgment, interacting with
other humans and doing
the right thing by each other
is grossly underestimated.
Doing the virtual version
of that if you must ask.
- [DRock] Carry on.
- I feel like I'm a
little startup toy for you.
I feel like you just
(wind up noise) (gibberish).
- [DRock] Sometimes,
sometimes you just don't do it.
- Yeah, sometimes I'm just
like, "Shut your face."
Don't bother me ever again.
(hip hop music)
I'm really well,
how are you guys?
1 million.
It's a win-win with or
without them.
(hip hop music)
Think I just connected
my Instagram to my
cell number.
- [DRock] Oh no.
- Can't remove
your phone number?
Yep.
Text Tyler and tell him
I can't call Joyce because...
That was interesting.
I don't get a lot of calls
from numbers I don't know.
Listen to this.
- [Woman on Phone]
Gary, if this is actually you
I don't think you realize
your phone number is
on your Instagram.
My name is Alyssa Taylor
and I have Allie here and we are
your biggest fans.
And we met you at ICON 2016
and you're fucking amazing.
(inaudible)
- Yep.
So yeah, my phone was public
on Instagram for 39 seconds.
Should I call back?
- [DRock] Yeah.
(phone ringing)
- [Woman on Phone] Hello?
- Is this Alyssa and Allie?
- [Woman on Phone] Oh my God.
You're joking.
This is not happening right now.
- This is super happening.
My phone is --
- [Woman on Phone]
I'm freaking out.
- [Woman on Phone 2] Is this
your personal phone number?
- I was connecting my Instagram
to a business profile and for
like 39 seconds my phone number
was there and your guys' hustle
got it so I wanted to call you
back and give you love and
daps for your hustle.
- [Woman on Phone 2] We were
just about to record a video
and text it to you.
- I love it. I love it.
Alright, I have to go make
a call but I wanted to
say what's up.
- [Woman on Phone 2] Okay.
Thank you so much we'll record
a video and send it to you.
- Okay, bye-bye.
(laughter)
I may not need to shower.
Showers tend to be like
anything before nine.
8 AM, 7 AM, 6 AM because I'm
waking up so and I sleep.
There I should have a good
night's sleep and leave at six.
It will be kind of in between
I still would want a shower
so take a look.
- [Jason] Hey Gary.
- Hey Jason.
- [Jason] How are you my man?
- Well.
I'm about to make this fucking
video for you while I sit
in this hotel room.
So real quick as I'm reading
through the notes is
when you guys in the notes
it says what's in it for
the distributors and the
salespeople obviously I know
them very well is this why, why
they should be excited that
(censored) is spending money
and doing marketing
in these channels.
Yep.
Alright, brother.
Yep. How you doing?
- [Jason] I appreciate
you doing this Gary.
- No worries, I'm sad I could
make it because obviously that's
a perfect venue for me.
What's up gang?
This is Gary Vaynerchuk,
CEO of VaynerMedia.
Because there's way
too many 20-year-olds, heck,
there's way too many 40, 50 and
60-year-olds that think they
have to make a million
a year to be successful.
- [DRock] Cool.
- Cool.
- [DRock] Ready?
- 24 months ago me in this
good-looking character named
DRock ran into a
room at VaynerMedia.
What's up Gary VIP?
It's me GaryVee.
In New York City, my hometown.
Can't wait to bring the thunder.
But are you ready?
Yay. My first lively.
Finally, Jesus,
I finally got in.
A big fan of all
of you guys back.
Hope you guys are
enjoying my Musical.ly stuff.
Huge fan of yours too KevRo.
This looks a lot like Facebook
Live. Can I heart it too?
Oh I can do my own heart.
I can add somebody?
Oh, I can share on
Twitter, got it.
Alright this is pretty cool.
Post there. Very cool.
Age. Go, go.
12, Mattie good
stuff, young hustlers.
30 legit great number,
12 K Burns love it.
51, 14, 33, 29.
Love it.
Love, love, love.
27, 35, 10.
Boy Athlete is a 10-year-old
hustler that's what
I'm talking about, baby.
Yes, Boy Athlete.
Love it.
13, Monkey money.
Monkey money, baby, 13-years-old
I would have been so hard-core
as a 13-year-old hustler.
- [DRock] That'd be pretty cool.
- Yeah.
Could you imagine looking
back at my 13, 14,
15-year-old business videos?
Love it.
Alright a little
fun with lively.
Much love to everybody.
Go Jets.
Way and I mean way
too many of you,
way too many of you
are doing shit you hate.
Once in a blue moon maybe
several times in your career
you'll embark on an adventure
where even from the minute
you start it you know that
it's going to be something big.
But it depends where your
head's at right now.
August.
- [DRock] I love it.
- It's good, right?
- [DRock] It was really good.
- Yeah, I think I got something.
Guys, I'm super
pumped up right now.
I think I just made
a big time video.
DRock?
- He really did it.
- I think I got something.
It's called August.
- [DRock] Do you want coffee?
I think there's some
food coming, right?
Hey man.
- This is Ivan.
- [Ivan] Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Ivan.
How are you?
- Pretty good.
- [Gary] Good, man.
- [Man 5] DRock.
- What do you think of
Snapchat's little decision of
the whole memory stuff?
- Smart.
- [Man 5] Really?
- Mhmmm.
- I think the UX is poor though.
Keep hitting like
every time I go to snap.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- I haven't.
You have?
- [DRock] Yeah.
It's right by the button.
- Seems like you guys
have inaccurate thumbs.
So this dude and this
dude are mad about
the little button below.
- It's infuriating.
Look you even have a
cheering crowd in your room.
- Sounds like
inaccurate thumbs to me.
I've never hit it.
I didn't even know what the hell
you guys were talking about.
I know that but I
didn't know you designed it.
Yeah, I have to.
- I have to take a picture.
- I like rock that
shirt all the time.
- I know. Everybody sends
me messages. I'm like I know.
- I know. I know.
Hey man.
- How's it going?
- How are you?
- Tyree.
Real pleasure.
- [Woman 6] My security guy.
- [Gary] Fits the mold.
- [Woman 6] I told Keith
before he leaves tonight,
that's all I want is a picture.
- [Gary] Is a picture of that.
I love it.
- Everybody let's give it
up for Gary Vaynerchuk.
Give him a warm welcome.
(cheers and applause)
One last thing before
we dive in,
very first question is this
what box does this
maker belong to?
- Donruss?
What?
(cheers and applause)
Don't sleep on my skills.
- Question number two--
- Fuck I'm so
pumped I got that right.
- What is the name (inaudible)?
- Go ahead.
Oh fuck, I have no idea no idea
who the guy Nolan Ryan shared
his rookie card with.
Koosman?
- Koosman is right!
- What? What? What?
(audience laughter)
Holy shit.
- Number three--
- I hate this fucking guy.
(audience laughter)
- What year and make is
this basketball card?
- '90 Fleer.
(audience laughter)
Guys, guys you all know me this
is the only thing I gave a fuck
about for eight
years of my life.
Think about that much intensity
deployed against
one little narrow thing.
- Next question
and we got one more.
Next question, whose
rookie card is this?
- Ernie Banks?
- [Sean] Yes!
Ernie Banks.
(applause)
- [Sean] Next question this is a
Donruss blank rookie card.
- Rated Rookie.
'80 Topps.
- [Sean] '80-what?
- I got it wrong.
Then I got a wrong 'cause
I thought it was '80,
oh this is '83.
- [Sean] '83 Topps.
- Yep.
- [Sean] One last question.
(inaudible) Who is this player?
- Roberto Clemente.
- And there is
Roberto Clemente.
Good job.
(cheers and applause)
The stage is yours.
- I'm going to be so upset about
that Ozzie Smith fuck up for the
rest of the night.
Can you go home and
create more magic?
I'm not sure. Right?
I think we can talk about that a
little bit. I think it has a lot
to do with self-awareness.
I think a lot of you in
this room want to be something
instead of reverse
engineer what you actually are.
Can you really go home and
become Sean and have that level
of charisma and have that?
I don't know.
I've always felt the
talent could be honed.
You could maximize, by the
way, your kicks are phenomenal.
I think you
maximize your talent.
I feel like I have
a certain amount of
basketball talent in my body.
Sure, I can play every day but
can I really get to that extreme
level where I could be
on a basketball card?
Just punchline the answer is no.
I do not believe that you sit
here and you fly into Vegas you
sit up here and listen to all
these great speakers a lot of my
homies have spoke earlier and
I don't think you go home
and scale magic.
And so I love Sean with all my
heart but here's one thing
I can promise you.
You can all go
home and hustle more.
(applause)
Thank you.
- That was amazing.
- There's something inside.
- Oh my God, that's awesome.
Jets Poké, that's
fucking unbelievable.
Got it.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- My best friend right here man.
- He's the man.
That was good.
That was a good one.
- Did you love the card thing?
- Loved it.
I did so well in it.
- He did so good.
You're like I don't know.
- I told him he's gonna be
pissed about the one he missed.
- I'm so pissed.
- He got eight and we were
like he's going to be pissed.
- I forgot '80 and '82.
Yeah, I forgot '80 and '83.
- What about that video?
I got goosebumps.
- Dude, that
video is so awesome.
- [Sean] If you guys
ever want to use it--
- Oh, we want it,
we want it, we want it.
We want it.
- [Sean] This is the guy
who did it right here.
- [Gary] Dude.
I love the video, good shit.
Such good work.
- A lot of concerts in
this place right here.
- [Gary] I'm sure.
I know, she's adorable.
Sup brother, how are you?
- Good.
How about you?
- [Gary] Good.
Hey.
Sup brother, how are you?
- How are you, man?
- [Gary] We've
all got our stuff.
And I think that, I think
the quicker you realize yes
I may have more self-confidence
than you but you may have
things that I don't.
I just don't spend any time
thinking what all of you have
more than me.
I just focus on honing what I
have more than you 24/7/365.
- [Woman 7] Yes.
- Yeah.
You got it.
(applause)
Yeah.
It's your accent,
it's your this.
It's 'cause your mom told
you weren't good enough.
There's so many things.
What's your alternative?
I just think that
people are scared to
fail in front of other people.
My friends, I'm telling
you something right now,
I'm desperately excited to
fail in front of you.
Because A, I don't really give a
fuck what you think and
B, I'm gonna learn from it and
C, battle scars are attractive.
I think that what's holding you
back is what you think other
people are going to
say about it. Right?
You like that, bro?
- [Man 8] Yeah.
- [Gary] Thanks man.
It's just like if you want to be
an unscathed entrepreneur and be
undefeated, you're not
going to be that great.
Entrepreneurship is
like UFC, everybody loses.
And the second you wrap
your head around that you have
dramatically higher potential
because then you will push
yourself further because you're
not going to be scared to fail
and the people that are scared
to fail stay within a comfort
zone and can only
hit a certain level.
When I started VaynerMedia
do you know what
everybody said on
Madison Avenue?
"Twitter boy is
starting an agency ha ha ha."
That didn't scare me.
That made me want to rip their
fucking hearts out
of their body.
(laughter)
And if I failed,
then they were right.
Where's that lovely gal who said
like "I'm going to win," right?
I'm like, "Show me."
I hear you but until
you do, you haven't.
I think you're just worried
about failing in front of
somebody beside yourself.
Because you got it this far so
that means most of you are not
scared to fail for yourself.
You're scared to fail and
then somebody else that you care
about is judging you.
I just don't give a shit what my
parents or wife or kids think.
Yeah.
And that's an important thing.
Of course of care
I care what they think.
But not more than what
I think about myself.
And if you're lucky enough
to make that tweak,
shit just opens up.
Guys, this was a lot of fun.
I like I'm literally trying to
milk it for another second and
I think I'm gonna miss a super
important fucking flight so
I think your actions always
speak louder than your words so
I really appreciate the love.
This was super fun.
I need to figure out how to do
this for 87 straight hours one
day and I love you
guys, take care.
Thank you.
(applause)
(light music)
Interesting day.
San Francisco,
speech, bunch of business calls.
Actually documented
a lot of that today.
And then where'd we go? Here.
- [DRock] Lot of videos.
- [Gary] Vegas, a lot of videos.
We'll show one word from all
those videos I recorded.
That could be a fun edit.
Now, Vegas to LA.
Got some morning meetings.
Real hustle day.
Two flights back
and forth, two talks.
Bunch of business,
VaynerMedia stuff in between,
lots of phone calls.
Running a business
through this phone.
Good day.
It felt good.
Should be a good episode.
See ya.
(hip hop music)